action fraud two words you would never
associate with the united states of
america
now a phrase that could send fists
flying in the country
allegations of cheating have also
outgrown the issue of a vote recount
as some republicans claim they've been
conned elsewhere too
on social media you know the people that
that i hear from of course
believe that conservatives were
wrongfully being silenced
while those on the left that were given
basically free reign of your platforms
and one of the points of contention that
is often brought up
is that you do recruit heavily from
california which leads to your employee
base skewing quite heavily
to the left at first glance the
allegations that facebook's non-partisan
algorithms
have been tweaked to give biden an upper
hand
don't seem to hold after all biden and
his team
have been rather unflattering towards
the platform
to say the least i've never been a big
fan of facebook as you probably know
i've never been a big zuckerberg fan but
the latest reports suggest
that this could all be smoke mirrors
and that facebook is already buttering
up the new white house landlord
from promoting content which rubber
stamps joe biden's talking points
to secretly screwing tight the traffic
for publications by
non-mainstream and pro-republican
outlets
it resulted in a spike in visibility for
big mainstream publishers like cnn
the new york times and national public
radio while posts from highly engaged
hyper partisan pages
such as breitbart and occupied democrats
became less visible
facebook denies any bias explaining it
strives to achieve
balance to the best of its ability but
some actions speak louder
suggesting a mutual affection the
supposedly
facebook loathing joe biden doesn't seem
to have a problem hiring from their
[Music]
roster
biden's deputy communications director
also seems to have had a change of heart
and deleted tweets giving facebook a
dressing down
big tech controls the information in
this country they control
who sees what they censored conservative
news big tech has been working towards
us for four years
and they've been looking forward to uh
ensure that joe biden wins
uh their party is the democrat party uh
and so of course uh joe biden is going
to be stacking his transition team
with members of the uh silicon valley
cabal
so of course you're going to see former
ceos from facebook
um from uh from other technology
companies
uh they are these are joe biden's people
uh big tech is for the democrats and
look what we've got coming up now
we've got four years of the media which
is going to be puppy dogs
we'll not hear a peep nothing to
criticize here we're already gearing up
in this country for
a return to the swamp as we call it a
return to normalcy return to
warmongering
a return to um big pharma return to all
these uh
um uh industries that love the democrats
that love globalization
and they got their man in with with joe
biden previously
facebook has repeatedly found itself in
hot water with the us authorities
it seems this time the giant has finally
learned its lesson
and is preemptively raising the hand
that could very soon
be feeding it